what's up log Gary be here really
excited about this episode long day in
Copenhagen did a bunch of content this
first keynote which was the first
session there I thought was extremely
strong I think there's some pretty
remarkable insights and I hope you enjoy
it and here it is I know many of you
have waited a long time for this I know
that I have so I think we should all
just get on our feet and put our hands
together and welcome Gary Vaynerchuk
thank you thank you for coming that was
nice that was nice yes thank you guys
thrilled to be here you could get used
to that yeah to help air the session get
started some of you have prepared some
questions so let's get started with that
and do you have the mic runners ready
okay are you ready Gary I'm always ready
yeah perfect
so and are you ready okay perfect
well would you like to say a little
about yourself before we start oh yeah I
mean for the people in here who are not
familiar I guess the best way for me to
quantify what I'm about is I'm a serial
entrepreneur I was born in the former
Soviet Union came to the US as a kid and
you know really you know invested in
Facebook and Twitter and uber and tumblr
and did very well and investing built my
dad's liquor store business in the late
90s on the back of modern day marketing
and execution which at the time for the
kids in the room was even having a
website in 1996 not thinking the
internet was going to be a fad and then
built businesses on the back of email
and Google AdWords and then YouTube and
then this whole social media run and I
think you know a lot of what I'm
thinking about in this journey we're
about to take over for hours between
this Q&A session the keynote I want to
deliver and other things were doing is
the more I think about it the more I
realize how much of it was mental
perspective self-awareness emotional
intelligence the tactics are very
important but they're incredibly
commoditized how to run a Facebook ad or
you know what a good deal on an
influencer is is very different than
really reverse engineering who you are
and putting your company or yourself
more importantly in a position to
succeed so you know I think I'm an over
developed emotional intelligence
entrepreneur which is confusing because
my persona my shtick my showmanship
speaks more to sales and
aggressive alpha dynamics but I would
argue that I'm dramatically more in the
listening business than I am in the
talking business if one ever had the
time to actually see what's going on mmm
perfect well let's get started then now
are you in the room yep could we have a
mic well ed milady over here back in the
back so man ID will ask you her own
question yep we'll come for you now
hello Carrie how are you I have been so
excited being here so and think I would
really like to ask you what is your
number one marketing advice and I'm
thinking about online marketing so
whether it's online or offline Marta I
would tell you that the thing that has
been most interesting to me coming from
entrepreneurship or or liquor store
retail or the really entrepreneurial
Silicon Valley startup world to now
being in the last seven years spending a
lot of times with the biggest brands in
the world global brands I'm stunned that
people are not consumer centric I would
tell you my number one marketing advice
is to be empathetic
everybody's so selfish when they market
they want the customer to do what they
want them to do instead of the way I
think about it which is more
counterpunching which is listen to what
your customers doing that you're trying
to sell and market to and formulate a
marketing strategy around that and so
for me the reason I today push Facebook
so much is because that's scale whether
it be to B or B to C Facebook is
underpriced attention that the masses
are paying attention to and if you
become an amazing practitioner in the
pictures written words audio and video
of that medium you win so when people
watch television or listen to radio or
read magazines then you to be good at
that craft
my number-one marketing advice is
empathy and then skillset around once
you realize where they are and to me in
November 2017 that is to become the
disproportionate best facebook marketer
that you could be thank you now hey
lemme put hope where are you
do we have hello yeah yeah how are you
hi how are you today great to see you so
I am actually in the Facebook marketing
business and sometimes my clients they
say something around they don't want to
market themselves too much they're
perfectly yeah personally maybe they
like therapists so they run some courses
whatever and we're ugly but sometimes
people have this feeling that they don't
want to yes be too much in other
people's face yes do you have advice
that I would tell you that you should
not convince them of that you know
people because I'm so out there people
always like okay should I build a
personal brand for my business you know
should I be in their feet at five times
a day every day I think the answer is
not necessarily
right I think to me I think it's
reverse-engineering the individual you
know now if your business is selling
yourself as a fitness instructor or a
lawyer or a financial investor or a real
estate agent you're gonna want to be out
there right and if the question is more
about the difference between alpha
American DNA where you're out in front
and other parts of the world where
people are more reserved you know at
some level it's very difficult to make
somebody do something they're not
comfortable with they'll never be good
at it I want to remind everybody some of
the biggest companies in the world you
don't even know the name of the CEO let
alone what she or he looks like so just
because there's certain people taking
advantage and others of the opportunity
of building personal brand as a branding
mechanism to build their business it
doesn't mean it's the only way to do it
and so I never try to commence
people to build their personal brand or
be out there more I remind them that if
they're good at it and enjoy it is it
incredible II owned and controllable IP
that is unbelievably scalable but I
would tell you that I don't think this
is a one-size-fits-all situation in
environment and so I'm not overly
passionate that everybody needs to build
their personal brand but there is
significant upside if you can knit vas
upstairs
Brad Brad Forest brother
thank you Hey okay don't come I'm sure
thank you so much for the enormous
amount of content that you provide the
regular people with that's quite
surprising thank you and I have a
question for you
how do you start to market the service
that people who currently don't see as
something that they would benefit from
first you have to really wrap your head
around humility right my entire career
has been around this question when I
first got into the wine business I tried
to make Americans drink Spanish wines
New Zealand whines you know wines from
obscure places in France like the mad
Iran and languid Ock and because I saw
that being my opportunity I felt that I
was a disproportionately good marketer
and storyteller
that there was more arbitrage and me
bringing these brands and these regions
to the surface as you can imagine when I
started talking about social media in
2007 and a nine you know as a lot of you
know most companies still don't believe
that social media is ROI positive that
that is nine years later and so the
first thing I would tell you is too many
people get frustrated when they're going
into this kind of world if the market
doesn't perceive the value of it that
means that you're making a bet that it's
true and that over the next 24 to 48
months they will become it's longer than
that you'll be out of business
but time you were proven to be right you
know it's not fun to be right and not
get the benefits of being right because
you were so dramatically early like cool
I understand that you know that VR is
gonna happen and virtual reality is
gonna happen
the problem is it's gonna take 20 years
before it's at the scale that may
benefit for the way that people are
building their businesses today so I
would first say humility and then you've
need to go on a hardcore education
pounding how many people here have been
following my content for more than five
years raise your hands
so these 1215 people I've been saying
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] for a decade every
day for free at scale more than any
goddamn human being on the mobile device
and I still have to do it every day all
day to everybody and so it's enormous
patience and empathy and make sure that
your timing isn't too far ahead and then
finally just continuously looking for
underpriced attention because you won't
be able to afford to tell your story and
overpriced attention for too long if
you're selling something people aren't
ready for and then you've got to really
pound the value prop right I'm not into
social media cuz I like technology and
gadgets and I'm a technologist and I
think it's fun or cool I'm in it because
I think attention is the number-one
asset if you want to build a business
and I look for where it's under price
and overpriced and when I speak to it I
speak in business terms which eventually
get people to understand it in business
terms not because of the altruistic it's
nice to reply to somebody on Twitter and
so I would make sure that you're
speaking the language of the individuals
that you're trying to convert and that's
the framework you have to live in and
this model has the most upside but also
has the most graveyards thank you
then it's kind over here can we have a
micron oh thank you
he's fast hmm hi Gary welcome to Denmark
thank you for having me
like I guess a lot of other people in
here I am a entrepreneur with a very
small business I have three employees
I'm in the creative business I'm a juror
and that means that obviously I'm
wearing a lot of hats yes I call them so
my question is given all the things that
I need to do what percentage of time
should i allocate for marketing versus
what else versus everything in my case
talking to customers designing creating
jewelry handling my employees everything
admin decoration and you name it I mean
I think for how many people here are
entrepreneurs amazing so you have the
audacity to want to live life on your
terms and so I need hold the mic let her
hold it for a second my friend thank you
one more time hands in the air we have
the audacity to live life on our terms
the percentage of successful
entrepreneurs ones that can make a
living and live their lives on their own
back not in a company structure is quite
low the percentage of those that amass
the kind of wealth that everybody thinks
they're going to amass when they get
into entrepreneurship even is even
smaller than that the answer to your
question my friend is all of it all the
time always forever
and so and so to that point and that's
collecting the energy in this room I
think we all understand you're in a boat
there's marketing there's your employees
there are sales there's the product if
the jewelry isn't good who gives a [ __ ]
if the marketing is good it's not right
there's all these things and we're all
in a boat and here pops a hole and
you've got to go put your finger in it
and then there's one over here and your
toe and then finally it fixes and good
and now two more over here we are in the
firefighter business I am in constant
anxiety I have to be here for the next
four hours when I get off America has
started today my office is in motion its
we're six five six hours ahead there's a
lot that's about to happen in my
business in the next five hours and this
is fun and I'm obsessed with the
admiration and I I can't wait to take
selfies and high-fives and answer
questions and give a great keynote and
I'm so excited to be in this amazing
town and meet you guys and it's [ __ ]
incredible yet the second it's over from
the high of the high of people traveling
hours or I changed their lives I take my
phone and I have 17 headaches this
person quit and his clients mad and this
didn't go well and this is a problem and
did everything always forever because we
have the audacity to want it in this way
which is the best way to have it for a
human if you're capable
and let's find the capabilities to find
the next question Casper yep
hello Gary hello ma'am I do watch what
you do and not what you say I like it
but still I have a question I have a
lifestyle plant and a DJ collective so
I'm a DJ I'm playing after-hours today
so my question is my own like DJ
promotion or for me to yeah I see I
would probably do it if if there's
nothing that stands out - why not do
anything under your name I would do it
under your name because personal will
always over index versus a logo and I
think that we are now in the day and age
where people are okay with understanding
people are complete people and have
multiple things going on I remember the
early days of this people would have
like a very different life on Facebook
than they had on LinkedIn you know and I
would always laugh because they thought
they were tricking somebody like we all
know you know it's funny now that I'm a
parent my daughter is doing a lot of
things that I did and at 8 I thought it
worked now I just realized my mom was
letting me do it and laughing at me
and and that's how I think about why
it's okay to mix personal professional
you're not tricking anybody that you're
so professional with a nice picture with
a tie on LinkedIn while you're throwing
up on Instagram so I think we should
just embrace it and so I think the
personal part will always over index
over a logo
right
now it's time for yes bah yes over here
hey Gary how are you I'm good
so I have a micro question you don't
want to stand up I can stand up that
let's clap it up for him so I have a
micro question what kind of contents
you're the world's leading VR physical
therapy company be putting out on social
media um first of all yes but you need
to be putting out content that makes
people understand what the [ __ ] that
means right and yeah and make sense and
I'm making a joke but you know that's
exactly like that's similar to two
questions ago your job right now is to
get people to even understand what that
is I mean you know this is a room that
has a chance of understanding what that
means that 99% of normals have no idea
what you're talking about I think a lot
of us that are fortunate enough to
understand the cutting edge of marketing
or technology have one certain language
but then there's the rest of the world
the ones we're trying to sell to the
ones that don't over think they're copy
on a Instagram photo like the normals
and so for the normals and even for this
group we've got to really wrap our head
around what we are you know physical
therapy is I think we can theoretically
understand but I think the first thing
is you have to put out content to make
us even comfortable that it's not a
janky experience because I think the
ones that understand it understand it's
got a ways to go technology wise there's
a lot of things that are there and so I
would just over educate I think you know
I don't know if you follow me but when I
talk about documenting versus creating
and we're doing that then vlogging for
like the last year everything and so
then you've got to figure out if you're
doing that you're 3/4 of the way there
now you've got to figure out two core
things is it interesting and do you know
how to distribute it yeah you know
number two is down but one is like we're
talking about it's the education thing
that's maybe we're doing the
storytelling but like more explainer
videos or where we
I you know I think again it's a lot of
these similar answers like you need to
make entertainment content and
informational content you're gonna need
them both in a business like this and so
I just keep you know creating at scale
it's just imperative and and then I
would also think a lot about influencers
you know I mean if you've got good you
know tracking on what's going on on
Instagram or other platforms and you get
the luxury of having somebody maybe tear
an ACL or something of that nature and
you can get an influencer to go through
rehab with you I think there could be an
incredible narrative there I can bring
disproportionate awareness to your
product yeah makes sense Thanks you got
it
now it's time for stoyan oh okay he's up
there hey hey Gary how are you very good
get first of all thank you so much for I
follow it from 2014 thank you had a
video with you 99 talking about
different contexts and channels so my
question is actually had a couple of
questions um I'm uh speaker and I'm a
consultant in productivity and time
management and I do it for a year my
background is from movie producing and
since then you think I'm sort of one-man
army
as many people I guess and it's really
hard with sometimes with allocating the
time because I'm focused primarily on
content on delivering to customers and
to sales directly like reaching out to
customers but I'm also super curious
about influencers and I never done it
before but I was just wondering if it
will make any sense to allocate time
where am i right now with spinning some
of my time on influencers marketing
trying to reach out to people on
Instagram or maybe link to anyone better
so I just wanted to hear what's your
thoughts about that well I think look
again at the youth that you're at at the
ambition that you have you know I'm you
know a one thing that always scares me
about my narrative is people always ask
me how much do I sleep or am I an
advocate of not sleeping coz I'm not I
think people should sleep six seven
eight hours depending on your body I'm a
huge advocate and what the [ __ ] are you
doing the other 18 hours right and so
when I hear your question the answer is
of course you should you know you should
you're you you know you should test
everybody here should spend meaningful
amounts of time testing everything
everything you know that's what you're
supposed to be doing cuz you don't know
the answer for your specific nuance
if LinkedIn or a podcast or influencer
marketing or you know you don't know if
that's gonna be the turning point and
what you're doing is you're doing too
many things people are keeping their
time precious when it's their biggest
asset
people are not reinvesting money back
into their business because they want to
buy dumb [ __ ]
people are not trying things because if
they fail they worry about what other
people think about that failure and so
there we're all you know the answer is
yes to everything
I literally [ __ ] I'm like yes and I
can leave and go pluck and fly to LA
right now because the next three hours
is yes it's yes
so of course you should like what are
you doing for 18 hours a day find an
hour and do it for an hour every day to
get to the answer and then also
understand that the first 10 times you
do it it might not be right because it's
like you know I always talk about the
ROI people like what's the ROI of
influencers or VR or the ROI of those
ten hours reaching out to influencers
the ROI of a basketball is very
different to people to me it's nothing
to LeBron James it's a billion dollars
so all this stuff works it's are you
good at it is a whole nother question so
it's not just the ROI of trying it then
you got to get good at it nothing you're
good at right now you were so great out
the first time you tried it so of course
man like everything that's happening you
need to figure out how it works for your
business b2b b2c personal brand the
question is what are you doing with your
time you know and so that's why I I get
mad at people who want to be an
entrepreneur and watch four hours of
Netflix a weekend or and by the way
people need escapism you need to check
out you need to rest you have to be in a
mental place but the scrutiny that we
have to put on our time as young
entrepreneurs you know it's just time or
monday-- talent is the variable that
sits in current but the assets that
you're sitting with in the beginning of
time and then you mask money and then
you can use the money to save time and
you're just going back and forth and
everybody wants these big dreams and
they're not willing to work at the level
they need to when that's the advantage
they have so [ __ ] yes you should I just
want to wrap it up and that's the
biggest inspiration I got from you since
2014 just kept off the crop and just
[ __ ] work so thank you so much you're
welcome and I just want to say one thing
if that's your aim
[ __ ] you can work ten hours a week if
you're happy I'm happy
but don't go running around saying
you're gonna build a seventeen million
dollar business and think you're gonna
do that on twenty five five hours a week
that person doesn't exist anybody you
know who's built something meaningful
has worked for it I know people have
inherited money but they're not the one
that built it anybody know that built
something put in the work there's just
no shortcut it's like working out you
can't think about push-ups good
and before we take the next question you
can begin to wonder if you want to ask
Gary something because we got a few more
questions prepared but then it's up to
you the audience also well yeah you know
well we'll set you free
yonis over here how are you young oh
[ __ ] I can't believe I'm talking to you
man
total great brother it's gonna be okay
alright so my question is um in a very
very early stage of the startup my first
startup yep and on a very very tight
budget yep the first thing to focus on
the most important thing and how -
there's so much brother
so I mean it's so overwhelming that's
why I'm asking you I mean I think a lot
of what I just talked about is true the
biggest advantage you have right now is
your time it's your number one asset
you're young you should have plenty of
energy you're hungry you're ambitious
great you need to work every goddamn
minute you can it's the single biggest
thing you've got the other thing is you
need to figure out how to get leverage
right so you need to figure out what
that does that mean so what's the what's
the business right now it's a web shop
selling posters it's a what brother a
web shop selling toasters a web shop
selling posters yeah yeah so you're a
web shop that when you say posters you
physical yeah okay so you're trying to
sell them to people yeah
and how much does it cost you to make
them um 10 bucks right now it's a very
small piece of I gear in package so one
thing that I'm a huge fan of in the
beginning is doing a lot of work for
free and people get very mad at me for
this advice I don't know why cuz they
debate me in theory instead of actually
ever living a business you know one of
the things that you're looking for is
awareness you need to know let people
know you exist one of the great ways to
do that is to do free war
for people that have awareness you're
giving them work they're giving you
awareness so I would have a hard core
strategy in the market that you're
trying to fulfill to do free work and
reach out to the companies or
individuals and say I want to do this
for you for free because I like your
work this is the kind of work we do
would you like it and by the way I have
a thousand people a day offer me free
and I don't take them up on it because
the value exchange of the time is not
worth it so just because you even offer
it for free doesn't mean they'll take
you up on it but the number one thing I
would do first if I was your partner was
I cool
let's get side jobs let's sell [ __ ]
let's do something else to mask dollars
let's let's borrow money let's rent
money let's raise capital or let's take
our money that we have together to do as
much free work for the biggest celebrity
the biggest athlete the biggest business
the coolest thing the coolest festival
the coolest brand free as long as we're
getting awareness out of it to build our
brand to then create deal flow all right
you think that's possible to with a very
tight budget so you're meaning that I
have to work free for them or then I
have to provide some of my products for
them for free both free and free which
could mean that you may have to get a
side job at night or borrow money or or
have a separate business altogether but
you or do services for other people at
low costs like what I get surprised that
people don't understand is what are the
alternatives like why are you asking me
this question you're asking because you
don't have the answer right now because
there's not that many alternatives when
you don't have a lot of money and nobody
knows what the [ __ ] your product is
exactly right so entrepreneurship is
super fun and cool on Instagram but in
real life it sucks [ __ ] so you know
doing [ __ ] for free is not fun go ahead
I'm just saying that I have a part-time
job right now so you feel good yeah and
I'm working on this after hours great so
you know the place you just you just
want me to use all the money for the
business right yes yeah so don't buy
another thing no more nice jacket
that's what my mom so respect yeah
that's good that's good yeah
I I think a small company that makes
posters number one arbitrage is to make
posters for free for things that will
give them awareness when people like who
made that poster if your brand's they
are things of that nature that is your
number one move you can do when you're
tiny and so you just need to be able to
afford that including selling the nice
jacket that your mom gave you thank you
man but you know what real quick because
it's a funny moment it's just very true
like like there's a reason immigrants
over-index and success that's the kind
of [ __ ] they do they don't buy anything
they they live in a place that has a
shitty house for seven years and save
every dollar even though they could have
moved out two years earlier or four
years earlier non entrepreneurs as soon
as they get a little money by dumb [ __ ]
instead of putting it back into their
business and so like it seems like a
funny joke but like when you have no
options you have no options like it's
not miraculously gonna happen and
everybody got tricked because I venture
capital of funding and everybody thinks
they're gonna write a business plan on
paper and go out and find some
miraculous VC and then they complain
well in Denmark and Norway they don't
have good VCS but Silicon Valley Silicon
Valley is a [ __ ] [ __ ] - they'll take
the meeting but not gonna give you money
either and so we need to be smart and
more practical that's real life thank
you
okay Kelly where are you down here can
we get a mic back in the middle yeah
here we go oh my god Gary Vee is in the
house that I'm about to ask a question
yes you are okay I carry
how are you about so very good if you're
about to open Australian Park in
Copenhagen in around four month how
would you approach to marketing until
the opening and after okay let's start
with the four months is that an
arbitrary thing or is that a hundred
percent locked in like why for months I
had a meeting with the owner the boss
yesterday and he wants me to run it but
he wanted to do the marketing and and I
asked him what would you do Facebook ads
and Google s and that's it that's what
you asked him yes he would he would do
the marketing with Facebook yes and and
and Google Ads and that's what he wants
to do that's it okay and I'm what would
you do I'm very I'm very high on that
you know I kind of did a little bit of
homework on like the attention arbitrage
in Copenhagen before I got here I think
that's cool I would just add influencer
marketing on top of that I think there's
a lot of Instagram snapchat Facebook
personalities that I think can bring
disproportionate attention to this and
are underpriced it's incredible to me
that there's a lot of individuals in the
copenhagen metro area and suburbs that
you could invite for free that even have
719 fans or 3,000 fans on some of these
platforms that the ROI of you giving it
to them for free for the photo is worth
it for you from a business standpoint so
I would say those three and then look
it's very abstract to say you're gonna
do Facebook and Google really
understanding the content that you need
to make in a Facebook environment is
incredibly important so you know you can
waste $10,000 on Facebook in a month
very quickly if you don't know what
you're doing and so just make sure that
you guys have a deep understanding on
the kind of content that will convert
are you trying to and then also the four
months before one to four months after
in the four months before I would drive
them to a landing page that has a Google
Form that fills out so that you can use
that data to remark it when you open
then after the fact you're driving them
to a place where a frictionless you know
conversion to the tickets or the
packages that you're selling what about
something like make people you know the
journey of now were you here now they're
manufacturing the the trampoline parts
enhances you know this is the thing
similar to be our physical service this
is the thing that I want to make sure
everybody understands cuz a lot of you
are paying attention to what I'm doing
and I'm a believer I'm a believer in the
documenting the journey instead of
creating I just want to remind everybody
that there are millions of documentaries
made every year but only thirteen of
them are things that people want to
watch so yes I believe it but can you
and can he and can others make a great
yes documentary on the journey that
makes people really want to watch and
fall in love with the characters you and
that that is a real challenge but if you
can do it yes I'm super interested in it
and I want to remind everybody that's
now thinking about this first time
they're hearing it there's so much young
talent out there that just want to get
there you know you know their first work
out there as a videographer or as a post
editor I believe that everybody here can
hire two to three incredible creative
interns pay them very little but there
are a why is the work and they get a
body of work and that's an incredible
opportunity for both parties we've never
had people that have been editing on
YouTube since they were six years old
and are now seventeen are producing this
kind of quality
post-production that is not the world we
grew up in and so I think yes and keep
in mind that you might be able to grab
the extra hands even for a poster you
know like the fact that you can get
somebody to work for free because for
her the documentation output is a
project she can point to if she changed
uses to take that risk because she has
the same mindset as you to work for free
I think there's a lot of creators out
there that are looking for opportunities
minimum wage free and obviously there's
laws and you'll have to navigate what
the reality of what you can do but very
low cost high quality creators are in
the system right now another thing for
you to think about look for sure if you
can make a vlog of the road leading up
to this but I'm telling you right now
brother it's hard to get people to get
really excited and watch
I don't want you to disproportionately
put too much energy into it or be
thoughtful and go all in for six to
eight weeks and if you don't you know
you've got to be smart about that can't
be ideological about documenting versus
creating can't be ideological about
anything you know theories only as good
as the execution that creates the result
that you want things that I believe in
change by the minute if I don't like the
way the cadence of the attention or the
platforms are evolving so my religion is
never what guys talked about last week
or last year my religion is what's
happening right this minute in the
creative and distribution opportunity of
communications to create the donation
the voting for my candidate the opening
of my trampoline park you know I I worry
that people that follow me think that
these things are set in stone because
they've not been carefully watching last
10 years where I will change my point of
view on anything other than if I think
your attention is in a place that's
under priced that's where I want to be
thanks a lot you got it
now for Maria Elena where are you here
can we get a mic mother down here right
here yeah perfect hi hi I'd like to ask
you what the one thing that you make
sure to do every day to keep
straightening your online performance is
to deploy gratitude that the seven
people I love the most are healthy okay
that's the real answer that I'm not sure
if it brings anybody any value or maybe
it brings a lot of people a lot of value
that's the truth like none of this works
unless I'm in the right you know
grateful passionate excited about it
standpoint cuz all this [ __ ] is hard and
so for me all of this is mindset there's
no tactic there's no double checking the
copy on my facebook post there's no
updating the picture on Instagram
there's no looking at all the replies on
Twitter all of that is so secondary to
am I in a good place to do the amount of
work that is required to do more more
and more more MORE yes yes yes yes yes
it's why I'm so fearful right now about
entrepreneurship because I think a lot
of people are doing it because it's cool
or it seems cool and it's so hard and so
lonely and exposes you so much that I
want people in the right mindset so
there's no tactic I do every day
other than consume and listen I read my
email I look at the replies on Twitter I
read all the replies from the night
before on Instagram from my pictures I'm
very qualitative I don't care how many
likes or shares I don't care about as
much about the data I understand it I
see it but I'm spending a lot more time
on the gray the vibes that I get from
the comments and engagement of the
community to give me an indicator of
what's working and what's not working
like a performer that does it's kind of
why I'm a good public speaker I'm right
now creating context on what you guys
are interested in and it's already
formulating my keynote that's gonna come
in an hour
based on this Q&A session that's good
that's what makes me good at what I do I
do that with my creative with my
businesses to be very frank with my
whole [ __ ]
like thank you welcome Marie yeah Lucy
yeah are you hi Gary I'm here hi thank
you for visiting Copenhagen thanks for
having me so when we talk about success
like in Gino
what do you define us your absolutely
personal success that's you know for me
I don't think about my absolute personal
success in the micro or the short term I
think about my ultimate personal success
in the long term so somewhere in about
15 to 20 years when I have a tremendous
read on who my two children are as human
beings that will be a very big judgment
day for me on my personal success in 25
years when a intern named Kathy that
starts today is running a huge business
and she learned at vaynermedia the right
things to do to build a huge business
that will be my personal success right
now I'm living out Sasha and Tamara's
personal success right now I'm a
byproduct of what my parenting and my
upbringing and my nuances my personal
success has a little bit more to go
and I think that's how I think about it
and as long as I am daily acting on that
long-term legacy North Star and that
everything that comes out of my mouth
and everything that I do
spends a disproportionate amount of time
on how Misha and Xander and the rest of
my family and my employees are affected
by it and what it sets up for them
that's basically how I think about I
live my life only only based on what
people are saying behind my back right
you know it's interesting right I mean
it's it's basically my framework you
know people always like man he's so nice
I'm nice because when I stop to take one
more selfie and and say hello and look
you in the face and listen to your
question
that's what you're gonna say about me
when I'm God and so I uh success for me
is not in the short term it's just you
know to me playing the game a success
waking up in the morning is success
being able to be Who I am a success
that's what I love about
entrepreneurship you're in control but
the absolute personal you know judgment
is a long long way away you know it's
very interesting for me I apologize it's
very interesting for me right now what's
happening in the world that people are
getting exposed a lot of people are
being taken down and I love that I love
it because the truth should be
undefeated I don't don't you know I like
that I like when merit wins when the
truth wins and so for some of us that
are living our lives that way this is
very exciting times Thank You Daniel yep
hey Jerry how are you doing good
I've been watching your Q&A ask every
and try to make my own version of it and
what's called a sappy inspiration Q&A so
it's a quite technical and that's my my
challenge here about how do I both make
it well technical how do we present
these things and as we talked about or
you talked about earlier here about make
it a bit more entertaining or two don't
you know if you're gonna make a
documentary which comes across as a film
there's got to be an entertainment value
because the structure of a film or
documentary is escapism where they are
to get caught up in the story so we
don't have to think about the real world
that's why we like music sports and film
when you're doing something technical
you're in the utility education business
it does not have to be entertaining okay
you don't come across as the most
entertaining dude I've ever seen Thanks
like I'm being from being Frank guess
what though guess what
and I'm not razzing or making a joke I
need you to understand why this is
important if you [ __ ] know your craft
and you know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about and it's not gonna matter
how [ __ ] charismatic or funny you are
you will win on your merit you just
might need to be extremely patient
because when there's small niches it
takes time to hit any critical mass cuz
usually there is no critical mass and
the way you surround your team with
people that don't understand is if you
find people that do understand okay you
know theirs so that'll be the intern or
whatever that's right when I built Wine
Library for people that worked on the
floor that knew about wine they needed
to know about wine like I you know there
was plenty people that I saw and I'm
like oh she's an amazing sales person
but then when I asked her about shot
enough to pop if she didn't know what it
was that wasn't gonna cut it because the
business I was in was you expected to
walk in the store and you had questions
and he needed answers and it was
important so I don't think you should
run away into the entertainment I think
you should triple down into technical
utility and knowledge because that wins
- oh you know it may not get you you
know millions of followers on Instagram
but that's not what you're trying to
achieve you're trying to achieve what
you're trying to achieve and so I think
that that's great and I would triple
down on the depth not the width
okay so just more technical content and
then remember audio written video
have you had the take a step back yet
and be self-aware about which platform
you're best at communicating is very
important and then understanding going
forward just like yes yes yes all of
them all of you are going to have to
produce content in written audio and
video form to be relevant in the noise
that is coming in 2022 because you have
to let the consumer pick which medium is
best for them and you have to be
everywhere to really win I mean it can't
be everywhere right away I get it but
you have to wrap your head around that
and as for me somebody who could not put
three sentences together that make any
cohesive sense I needed to hire a
ghostwriter who is listening right now
to this video and transcribing it and
then is gonna call me and ask me five
more questions
and I'm gonna answer them and that's how
I make my LinkedIn and medium posts and
at first I couldn't afford that so I had
to give up on writing and how to wait
and so like we all go through these
journeys but these are you know you've
got to really give thought to the
mediums to you could have a very
successful super nish podcast where
you're just talking with stuff out and
the 1,800 people you're trying to reach
700 of them listen to the podcast you
will win if that's how narrow your world
is true and now it's your turn so do we
have the first up yeah yeah he picked me
yeah hi how you doing Simon how are you
so I actually don't have a question for
you I've been following you a couple of
years you've given me so many ideas and
thought of wakings
that I thought man I owe you big-time
but there's no way I can pay you back at
the moment so I thought I'll give you
something that might bring you a little
bit of joy and I know you're packing
with to whine quite a bit now but I just
realized that you're drinking on a white
wine I am but still so I'm bringing with
me appeared longshot another pop very
nice from 2011 I hope you like it is
what I can give you at just our way of
saying thank you man please go ahead
your pleasure thank you thank you so
much
you know what's amazing about life the
fact that I was just giving an analogy
of wine store knowledge and of all the
wines in the world that I used the
Shatan of the pop as the example which
is pretty esoteric and for that to be
the wine like that's what I'm always
like the universe is looking at me and
saying keep going you know it's
interesting now we have one more over
here Cass pop behind you yep thank you
oh how are you Larry guys real quick
just so you know between the other QA
and the keynote and the fact that we're
covering so much I've made a new
decision I'm gonna answer every single
person's question in this conference so
you better get way more extroverted and
start raising your hands because I'm
gonna systematically pick on you over
the next three hours
go ahead hi Gary how are you my name is
Vasily I've been watching your content
for more than a year actually saw your
life in Bucharest in brain mines if yes
that also possibility to ask you a
question there and just want to say you
know thank you so much for everything
you've been done and in Bucharest I
asked the quite shared my success as
well as a entrepreneur where I was
successfully building ecommerce store
with influencer marketing DMing hundred
people I know so my journey on the
fiverr.com platform and so you know
interest in fact that after that I saw
the keynote he posted and it brought so
much attention to my fire profile start
getting a lot of you know contact so I
just want to say you know thank you so
much for this it was an incredible
amount of opportunity okay and from this
you know freelancing I was able to build
as a social media marketing agency on
Fiverr and my question to you is I
started to you know work on my personal
branding and I got invited to some
conferences business conference to speak
and I want to ask you if I continue if I
start continue to you know expand
personal branding would help me get get
bigger clients yes you know we've yes
like bigger companies
or would bullet also just bring like
audience to you like you have a large
audience following you so do you what do
you have you know opinion on that
working person brand to both their gonna
happen okay thank you that's my opinion
beside thank you like both will happen
right and so what will happen is you'll
get bigger clients because what you're
doing is building brand I love when
people get cynical about personal brand
because I know there's cynicism around
it all it you know if you don't like the
word personal brand let's call it
something else
reputation yes if you have a bigger
reputation things will happen right i
what will happen is on the personal
brand side fans or audience not clients
what will happen is opportunity you know
every every single investment I made
that made me tens of millions of dollars
were built on the back of a personal
brand it built me opportunities that
created meetings for me it's how I got
to places of course reputation matters
it's always mattered but people are now
trying to comprehend what's happening
here because it's become bigger than the
mainstream media everybody here can be
as big as they want to be on merit and
skill and that's incredible because
there used to be gateway and gatekeepers
right so yeah both will happen and then
you'll decide what you want to do I
could easily make 30 million dollars a
year being Gary Vee I choose not to
because I still want to be a businessman
and that's why I have an 800 person
agency and that's why I'm gonna have 18
fires when I get offstage cuz I want to
build businesses I don't want to be just
a personal brand but that doesn't mean
that's wrong and there's a lot of people
who do that and if that's what you want
to do the more awareness you have you
will be given something called options
and let me promise you something options
are good yeah thank you Gary and you
know I want to ask is well for you know
fiber platform do you what are your
thoughts on that like if we're expanding
our services we're getting a lot of
requests where like top rated seller you
know in the top category for social
media marketing so what are your
thoughts on expanding that going fields
like production
doing production video maybe not
building like a brand think you should
use it as a gateway drug to bigger
scopes okay
thanks Gary and the last question sorry
for that but is there any chanse
possibility to have you know 10 15
minute talked to you one-on-one at some
point maybe in your future conferences
like in Stockholm or maybe it could be
just FaceTime or anything maybe in the
back half of 18 because I'm fighting for
every minute right now but if you send
me an email and say I'm the fiber guy
who asked 47 different questions and
I'll see that and we'll set something up
thank you so much better thank you
thanks so much now there's people
everywhere
great broken the ceiling who's next
yep hi Christine how are you thank you
for being here I didn't know you are all
until few days ago and I don't think I'd
learn to pronounce your last name but I
the only thing I know about you is I
watch one single of your videos and in
that one you were talking about one is
better than zero yes if you can get your
message across to one person is better
than to zero and that was at the time
what I was really dying to make videos
but I really didn't dare to put myself
out there so because of failure of what
people may think so I did this one video
and there was one people watching and
she became my client straightaway so I
just wanted to say that
it's awesome and the question very
briefly is like you know all the sales
funnel thing with the email marketing
and having a lead magnet and your
landing page and building up your
subscriber list I see a trend that
people are starting to scrap their email
lists and creating Facebook groups
instead so have their potential clients
into a Facebook group because that's
more interactive you can do lives and QA
and Sharons and life coaching and stuff
like that so I just wanted to hear your
thoughts about that because right now I
don't know what to focus my energies in
maybe the time both yeah yeah you know
like both let's talk it out here's why
it's important remember watch what I'm
you know you haven't seen as much of my
content a big thing I say is watch what
I'm doing not what I'm saying if you go
to Gary Vaynerchuk calm right now I want
your [ __ ] email I don't talk about
email the way I did in nineteen ninety
six seven eight nine because I think
it's established I think we all
understand what email is its potential I
used to have how many people here do
email marketing or have in 1997 I had an
email newsletter of 200,000 people for
wine that had 91 percent open rates
underpriced attention this isn't new for
me I'm just figuring out how to
articulate what I've been doing for the
last 20 years that's how I built a three
million dollar business to a sixty
million dollar business in five and a
half years that had no money making all
the right decisions so here's why yes
what happens if Facebook groups organic
reach they decide that that's a new
place they need to monetize and they
kill it and now you can't reach those
people like you have to both you never
want to be at the mercy of a platform
and you need to always have insurance
policies but people pick one or the
other
the new wave says yes facebook and
they're right there's more attention
their email as spam nobody's reading
their email it's not converting the same
way right the old guard says I'm not
gonna trust Facebook you know when
Facebook's you know newsfeed started
lowering organic five years ago they
were four years ago they're like aha
told you suck
the answer is both yes and yes as I
heard somebody whispering n right so
again I need everybody here if I leave
with anything and this is not the rock
will tell you this is not something that
I've been pushing very hard audacity you
have audacity who the [ __ ] do you think
you are who the [ __ ] do I think I am if
you want to live that life that you're a
[ __ ] coach and people should pay you
for the [ __ ] that's coming out of your
head
you better [ __ ] do both I'm saying
this because I want to pressure you just
like clearly when you saw that video
that clicked for you you can't put
yourself I never put myself in a
vulnerable spot and just relying on
Facebook as a vulnerable spot but it's
where the attention is so I had yet with
having email and SMS and my website and
my podcast and and and and and and and
I'm busy you know for offices 200
million dollars in revenue in vain or X
right like like two young kids like
[ __ ] in Copenhagen like like a
[ __ ] you know like and so if I'm
doing now my ambitions may be greater
but I'm still not gonna let you be in a
vulnerable spot where you wake up one
day and a platform makes a change and
you're like what happened people are
going out of business when they only
rely on SEO or just email or just a
wreck mail or just Facebook or just
Twitter
I wish Twitter stayed number one I was
one of the first people to have a
million followers
it was great it's how a lot of you first
heard about me that was my first
coming-out moment I loved it I didn't
want it to change i won you know how I
won by spending 15 hours a day replying
to people on Twitter for three and a
half years do you know what that feels
like when you wake up in the morning and
you realize Twitter's starting to lose
its attention do you know what I did I
took the punch in the mouth I spit my
tooth out and I started building
Instagram and Facebook I had no choice
so yes it's harder it's
more work but the alternative is ugly
you want to go work at a bank thank you
and unfortunately now I'm the show
Stuber okay that's my part of this I
think we're going away and coming back
right yeah I think why I think you guys
need to decide that maybe with you guys
is if that when I come back to the hour
for the keynote you know how much do we
want to continue the Q&A at scale
because so much of what I talk about it
is online to watch I'll let you guys
decide I'm thrilled to talk I'd love to
hear myself talk but I'm thrilled and
feel like there's a lot sitting I can
feel it in the Q&A part so you guys you
guys decide you guys decide but thank
you so much oh you can't leave yet
because I have I have saved actually a
very great question till the last so
before I let you go I have a break
Casper has a question
great I just want to ask you Gary let's
let's say there's this guy who has spent
a year to plan something plan an event
yes he spent all his money yes and he
feels that he has his debt he has it
down it's going and it's gonna be a
great and then the day before the event
something happens the email that's
supposed to go out with the last crucial
information
it goes haywire all of a sudden we have
a guy who has received 600 emails from
the organizer of this event sounds like
a terrible situation right yeah poor guy
exactly can you give an example of how
you sometimes turn something bad into
something positive
I had something like this happen so I
don't know no no not how did is
something like this happen I had all day
like this happened I also had an email
from Wine Library nine years ago
go out instead of once like 87 times
which made 11 percent of the list
unsubscribe
get reported to Google bla bla bla bla
and it was probably one of the best
things that ever happened to me because
what I did was in that scenario I to try
to parallel
this make pretend guy and what he should
do I went on my merry way I put things
in motion to get us back to whitelisted
get the data on what happened
I had to still run the store cuz it was
busy we gotta get packages out but when
that was done two days later if I recall
on the weekend I sat down and I called
and emailed every single person that was
affected for the next 31 days three
hours here eight hours there sounds like
this guy is lucky it wasn't eleven
thousand people which makes me think
it's gonna be a piece of cake to
personally call
look look this is super interesting I
don't know if I wrote this in the Thank
You economy which was a book I wrote but
I definitely have said this publicly I
believe that we expect things to happen
that we actually don't judge that much
on the bad thing we judge under the
thing you do next so much so that I have
at times thought about doing something
slightly wrong nothing crazy just
because I thought the apology would be
ROI positive to the entire so I think
something amazingly good just happened
let's see we will well you'll get your
chance later because Gary will be back
and we will of course talk about I think
one thing that we already thought about
was that we would very much like these
questions and we would like to make them
as interesting for everyone as possible
so we will make a small stand out here
there's a small elevates stand out here
and if you feel like you want to ask a
question you're more than welcome to
come and deliver your question and we'll
do a little bit of screening before so
we make sure that is relevant to
everyone here so I would also say if I
may since we're just shooting this [ __ ]
up here as somebody who's obsessed with
Q&A so much so that the reason I wrote
the askgaryvee book was I was hoping
would be so successful that every
keynote I would give for the rest of my
life would just be Q&A and it's because
it's very interesting and we just had a
bunch of people at randomly asked and I
think as an organizer there's so much
it's you actually make me very happy you
have such good intent to try to make the
question valuable and some people may
want to pitch or thank or things of that
nature and I get that but it is pretty
amazing doing this for the last year or
two more QA how much so many of these
things are universal 60 70 80 % of the
things we're all dealing with they may
have a different business but I think we
can all recognize in this last session
there were so many things that were
relevant to you that you would have
never thought to ask but my answer to
somebody else's question might have been
the unlock that you needed for where
your head's at so also something to
think about do my hands
later hey guys in my continued track to
continue to get feedback to make the
blog better would love to get insights
on what micro piece of content what
one-minute clip in today's vlog should I
cut out and make an Instagram post you
get to be the post Center forget iris
forget fab and forget the rock forget
Kyle forget Justin you get to pick the
one minute that we chop and make sure
you upload your favorite parts and we
will post it on Instagram with a shout
out to whatever Instagram handle you
want so make sure you put the time stamp
3 13 2 3 6 3 13 - 4 13 and put your
Instagram handle there I'll give you a
shout out my Instagram when we post it
see ya
[Music]
you
[Music]